foreign
thanks for tuning in today I'm here
today with Forrest head of developer
media at Google cloud and founder of the
cloud resume challenge so we're here
today to share our advice on how to
build Hands-On Cloud skills in 2023 but
before we get started please let us know
where you're tuning in from and pop in
any questions you'd like us to answer
throughout the session
welcome to the live stream Forest how
are you doing today hey Lucy I'm doing
great thanks for having me
thanks for being here so far as you've
had a really interesting career Journey
so far and you've made a big impact in
the cloud Community you know not just by
creating the cloud resume challenge but
also creating videos uh infographics
songs and other free content for cloud
learners but uh I'll let you introduce
yourself to those who haven't come
across you before so do you want to
start by walking us through your career
journey and also let us know what got
you interested in cloud in the first
place
sure Lucy you know I think uh my career
is a testament to the fact that you just
never know where you're going to end up
and so hopefully that's you know
encouraging to those of you who may be
watching and you're trying to figure out
what the shape of your career is going
to look like and you feel like you don't
have it all held in your head right now
that's okay I promise you no matter what
you think is going to happen it's
probably not what's going to happen uh
and that was certainly true for me so I
started my career
um as a like a SQL Server DBA I was a
devops engineer I I managed teams of
Engineers at large Enterprises that were
moving to the cloud I was a consultant
for a while and worked with more
startups and Enterprises helping them do
that I've done most of the things you
can do as a Hands-On cloud and devops
engineer and a lot of that was done in
the context of the AWS world so I used
to be in what they call an AWS hero I
was actually one of the original AWS
serverless Heroes I was very into
serverless in the serverless community
still am I guess uh and I I got really
involved with kind of trying to help
that Community get their head around
which at that time
was kind of Cutting Edge technology
and that really lighted a a fire in me
for trying to help people understand
these what are sometimes Arcane and
unusual Technologies in straightforward
or maybe even entertaining ways and so
you mentioned some of the like the songs
I like to do I draw cartoons and try to
just you know help people laugh and
learn a little bit at the same time uh
and and then I also try to you know put
uh technology in formats where people
can access it without feeling like they
have to jump through a lot of Hoops and
the cloud resume challenge is an example
of that the cloud resume challenge is uh
something that I started a couple of
years ago as a way to help people that
are brand new not just a cloud but to
technology in general I feel like they
can just strip out the extraneous fluff
and start learning start getting
Hands-On start building earlier start
learning like an engineer Engineers
typically learn uh without you know
maybe uh like watching a ton of videos
they like to get hands on earlier they
like to reach over and tap someone on
the shoulder when they have questions so
there's a big very active Community
Discord Community associated with the
cloud resume challenge we've seen
wonderful success with that over the
past couple years helping people
transition into Cloud roles from you
know wherever they may have thought they
were before
awesome yeah a lot of the taqualusa
community have come across the cloud
resume challenge before and it's helped
a lot of people with you know putting
their resume on the cloud and learning
cloud services and the good thing is
today's conversation will not just be
focused on AWS so for those who are you
know also learning agile or gcp it's
sort of like a cloud agnostic sort of
conversation will be the advice we
provide would be relevant regardless of
what cloud you're learning so let me
just pull up on this screen the slides
so as always we have a list of the top
five questions that we've collated that
we think might be interesting for the
conversation but also open to any
audience questions so again any
questions feel free to pop into the chat
and we'll sort of switch between the
questions on the screen and then also
the questions from the audience
so for us I'd like to start by asking
you a really really broad question which
is how do you gain hands-on experience
with the cloud and the reason I want to
ask this is because when I first started
learning cloud the big Focus was on
getting certified in certifications but
it seems like everything has shifted now
and you know people are realizing that
certifications only get you so far
because it's just you know at the end of
the day a multiple choice
um a quiz or exam so how do people
actually go that extra step to get
Hands-On Cloud experience in order to
land a job in the cloud which a lot
which is why a lot of people are
learning hard in the first place
it seems like a daunting question
doesn't it when you look at the wealth
of resources that are out there the
wealth of services that are out there
honestly the wealth of cloud options
that are out there now you know I I have
made a cloud transition myself from
being very involved in the AWS Community
as I mentioned and now working for
Google cloud and have had to learn a
whole new set of cloud capabilities some
of them feel very you know similar they
rhyme some of them feel very much like
their own thing uh and so I think one of
the first questions that people ask
themselves right at the beginning when
they're trying to gain Hands-On Cloud
experiences which Cloud should I even
get Hands-On with you know and I we get
this question in the cloud resume
challenge Community all the time I'm
sure you do too Lucy uh people saying
you know I I see like there's AWS out
there there's Azure there's Google Cloud
I'm a total beginner I don't have you
know like I'm not working at a company
where I have access to one of these
specific clouds so which one do I choose
uh and what I always tell people is the
the more important thing is to start
with something if you're junior you're
brand new you don't have any external
Force weighing you toward one particular
cloud provider it's more important to
get Hands-On with something than be kind
of paralyzed with decision fatigue
trying to pick the perfect Cloud all
three of these big major Cloud providers
have large communities they have lots of
job opportunities and like I said a lot
of those skills transfer pretty well
anyway sometimes I like to joke with
people and say you know there's probably
not a hiring manager out there who's
going to say oh well you have no
professional experience in Azure but
what we were really looking for is
someone with no professional experience
in AWS see what I mean it's it's like
when you don't have that job experience
to bring in it's almost like it doesn't
matter so much what you have on your
resume but that said there I mean there
are a few considerations you might want
to look at certain clouds maybe have
more of a presence in certain
geographical regions so if you look
around you in the country that you're in
and you see why there's a lot of Google
Cloud here well then maybe it's smart
for you to familiarize yourself with
Google Cloud but again I don't really
think you can go wrong with any of the
three Cloud providers as a junior what's
much more important is just to pick
something and die in and start building
skills and so with that said how do you
actually do that once you've picked a
cloud you want to jump in on how do you
actually gain hands-on experience with
that cloud I have nothing against
certifications I used to work for a
large training education provider that
was mostly identified with its
certification prep material that would
be a cloud Guru which is now part of
pluralsights and so I have a lot of
experience working with people that are
uh in it for the certifications and I
don't have any problem with
certifications I think they're an
important part of Cloud Learning the
cloud resume challenge actually asks you
to get assert as part of the project
that you do I think it's a great way to
get a fundamental overview and if you're
brand new to Cloud I think it's a great
idea to start with uh maybe like the
foundational level certification so for
AWS that could be the certified Cloud
practitioner for Azure it could be the
AZ 900 for Google Cloud will be the
cloud digital leader those are not
technical certs that are going to look
real impressive on a resume to a hiring
manager but if you're completely brand
new to Cloud they're going to give you
terminology and help you at least feel
like you're a little bit conversant with
the world you're about to step into so
that will be my pre-learning step before
I get Hands-On but once you have done
that I would right away start looking
for some projects to do uh and maybe
that moves us a little bit into the the
uh the second question but before I talk
about specific Cloud projects uh I want
to address one other thing which is
people ask well is the only way I can
get Hands-On Cloud experience to like go
do Labs that are associated with maybe a
training provider or is it should I go
and do uh maybe some kind of Hands-On
side project on my own or should I try
and do like freelance work or
Contracting or something right what's
what's going to be the best thing for me
to do
all of this is going to be situation
dependent not going to give totally
general advice here but I would say uh
the the
um uh maybe the effectiveness the value
of projects you're going to do is going
to be ranked in a hierarchy so like a
Hello World tutorial where yes quote
unquote I'm Hands-On but I'm just typing
in commands that someone else has
written down in a blog for me or I'm
just copy pasting I'm clicking that's
going to be the least valuable thing you
can do it's fine to start and honestly
even a lot of Professional Engineers
when they're doing something brand new
they might run through a Hello World
tutorial as their first step that's a
great way to get familiar with the
technology but that's not where the real
learning comes the real learning comes
when you start pushing yourself up
against things that the solutions not
explain for you and sitting there in a
document where you're going to have to
open some search tabs and you're going
to have to go down some rabbit holes and
you're going to encounter some error
messages that are going to frustrate you
and you're going to beat your head
against them a little bit that's where
real learning comes kind of that baptism
by fire because when you do find the
solution and you find it on your own
based on your own learning and research
it's going to stick with you much better
it's going to come up better in job
interviews that's hard one experience at
that point so I would as soon as
possible start pushing yourself toward
projects where you're learning in ways
that are a little bit self-directed and
where you're solving problems where the
answer is not already provided in a
pre-packaged format for you does that
make sense
yeah so you know starting off with the
foundations of potentially getting
certifications going through a few
guided Hands-On labs and then you know
try and be on your own for a little bit
try to create something that maybe
hasn't been created before or doesn't
have like an exact blueprint you can
follow step by step and just experience
the struggles right of trying to build
something uh it not working and then
trying to figure out the reasons why
really good advice then we have a
question from the chat uh kind of
similar to question number two on the
screen which is how do you gain access
to projects Hands-On so this person is
planning to take the solutions architect
exam soon which I think is a good time
to start yeah doing Cloud projects like
after doing the certifications because
that will give you that foundational
understanding of what are these services
and how they can be used
um so yeah to reach up straight into the
question number two then which is advice
and resources for cloud projects how
would you like to sort of address
Justice sure and I guess we've already
started getting into it a little bit and
talking about uh you know trying to
choose Cloud projects where the more of
the learning comes from you where you're
not just following someone else's cut
and dried set of instructions but along
with that comes a caveat which is you
can get way off in the weeds with some
project and you can go I don't know how
I got myself into this mess I don't know
how I'm going to get out of it and now I
feel very frustrated and disillusioned
and I just want to walk away from the
whole thing entirely so that's not where
you want to be and to avoid that it's
very important that you place yourself
in a community so that you don't get too
stuck believe it or not knowing when and
how to ask for help is actually a really
really important job skill right if
you're learning cloud for professional
development purposes you're not in a
school context there's no cheating here
right it's not like you somehow lose
points if you go and ask for help in the
professional world when you're on the
job you are likely not going to be a
solo Cowboy out there slinging code all
by yourself you're going to be part of a
team and it's going you're going to be
judged on your ability to solve problems
quickly and collaboratively not
independently so it's to your advantage
to know how and when to escalate a
problem how long to beat your head
against it before you realize okay yeah
I'm really stuck I need to go get
somebody else to look over my shoulder
for five minutes that's a very very
important very valuable skill and the
way to develop that outside of the work
world again is to build in community to
have other people around you that are
working on the same kind of projects
maybe similar career stage to you and
that you can that you can ask questions
of you can bounce your code off that you
can ask architecture design questions
get code review super super important
Cloud resume challenge has a Discord
community that does very well in that
respect Google Cloud actually has a
Discord Community as well that you can
join uh there's I know AWS has Discord
communities and slack communities as
well uh and then there's others that are
not affiliated with one of the the cloud
providers that you can find oftentimes
they're associated with different like
training companies or training providers
a club Guru launched a Discord server
when I was there as far as I know it's
still active and thriving so look for
communities like that where you can plug
yourself in that's really my top piece
of advice uh because doing Cloud
projects on your own the right kind of
cloud projects the good kind of cloud
projects the tough kind of cloud
projects that is not anything that
anyone wants to undertake a loan for a
long period of time that's way too
lonely find your people and keep them
close to you you will you will learn
much faster you'll grow much faster
uh so I guess those are some resources
as well um resources for actually what
cloud projects to do probably would be
the next question so we've mentioned the
cloud resume challenge a bunch of times
you can go to
cloudresumechallenge.dev it is freely
available you can try it there and I
always recommend this to people uh when
they start well because I wrote it for
people that are just starting out uh it
pulls a lot of skills into one project
if you do the cloud resume challenge
you're going to get some experience um
building a front-end static website
you're going to get some experience with
authentication you're going to get some
experience with Cloud networking you're
going to get some experience building a
serverless API you're going to get some
experience working with databases you're
going to get some experience working
with infrastructure as code with Source
control with CI CD a lot of the
operational as well as the development
things that you need to know to be a
cloud developer or really maybe more of
like a Solutions architect uh you know
devops engineer whatever you might say a
lot of people that complete the cloud
resume challenge go on into roles like
that uh there is a book associated with
the cloud resume challenge I think Lucy
might have like a discount code for
Linked In this chat
um and that book also contains some
additional project mods if you want to
get more into security or you're going
for more of a developer role or you're
going for more of a devops role things
that you can actually build right onto
your core Cloud resume challenge project
but just help you practice and learn
specific skills to tailor you for the
kind of job you want so that's the
project I always encourage people to
start with and you can reach out to me
personally anytime if you have questions
about that or need help getting started
you can do it on AWS on Azure or on
Google Cloud there's separate
instructions provided for free on the
website for each of those clouds uh
other projects you can do like I said I
used to work for a cloud Guru which is
now part of pluralsight they have a
whole raft of uh different projects that
are kind of in the spirit of the cloud
resume Challenge and I actually link a
bunch of those on the cloud resume
challenge website as well if you go to
the resources page you'll find projects
that will get you deeper with Google
cloud with AWS with Azure and they still
use kind of that self-directed mode of
learning but they'll they'll range you a
little farther afield in the type of
things that you're working on uh and so
that's that's where I would start um
again there's there's more you know
Cloud project opportunities coming out
all the time Andrew Brown who's another
Cloud educator I've seen he's got some
kind of cloud project boot camp that
seems to be floating around about to
start I don't know too much about that
but I do know that there's that type of
value being created by other Educators
here in the in the cloud world so uh you
know keep your eyes open join some
communities you're going to start seeing
projects and opportunities float up
amazing so follow-up question on that uh
people usually you know they see some
resources on cloud projects and they see
that AWS for example has like workshops
like AWS as a link that where people can
you know build projects that are more
guided step by step but then I get a
question that's on you know how many
projects are enough like how much should
I actually build and
like what about the complexity of them
like you mentioned like a hello world
project probably wouldn't be enough for
an employer perspective so what you know
what do you think uh would be enough
let's say for like a employer
perspective and also just the number of
projects to build would be your usual
recommendation on this so let's be very
real here getting hired in Cloud without
previous professional experience that's
in cloud or close to cloud is a total
crapshoot there is no industry standard
there is no obvious on-ramp there's no
guaranteed set of things that
interviewers are looking for you are
going to be throwing darts you're going
to be hoping that someone is on your
wavelength and understands the need for
apprenticeship and mentorship and can
bring you on uh I've met and worked with
wonderful hiring managers who get that
and then I've also worked with what I
call Cloud resume Champions people
who've completed the cloud resume
challenge who spend months and months
kind of beating their heads against the
wall trying to apply for jobs and they
just get told over and over again things
like oh you know you don't have a
college degree so the project don't
matter or why don't you go get some
experience with help desk or something
and then maybe you can work your way up
into Cloud so people hear that every day
I want to acknowledge that and be
empathetic to it because it is super
frustrating I think it's a failure of
the industry I think we as an industry
need to do a much much better job of
setting realistic expectations for what
it means for entry-level developers to
come in what it means for them to pair
with more senior developers so that they
can ladder up those skills in a real
hands-on experience type of environment
but until we get there we just have to
take the world as we find it right and
try to hack it where we can try to make
ourselves as uh you know show as much as
we can that you know we're the kind of
person that's uh a smart investment a
smart risk to take for a hiring manager
that's what it means to to apply for
jobs with only projects on your resume
so your question was how many of those
projects do I need
um I don't know that I am comfortable
giving a number because I actually think
that might be the wrong question for
most of us to ask instead I would say
think less about how many projects you
have because I could have 10 or 20 or 50
quote-unquote projects on my resume or
on my GitHub but if they're they're toy
projects or they're kind of inscrutable
or they don't look like anything that
you'd be likely to be doing on the job
like if I'm a hiring manager I'm busy
I'm skimming through that I don't really
care it's like okay so you did you
automated your lights at home all right
you did that I don't know what that
means for me in this job where we're
doing data engineering I don't really
know how to process that right so people
just gloss right over that kind of thing
instead I would focus more on the skills
that you're learning through the
projects it's not about the quantity of
the projects it's you being able to come
in and say okay look the basic core
building blocks of being a cloud
engineer so Linux networking you can
write decent code in a programming
language or two you understand some
cloud services and you've integrated
some things together as long as you have
done enough projects to be able to show
that and it could be just one it could
be one Mega project that you've added a
lot of things onto over a little time it
could take you several to get there but
as long as you can show that set of
capabilities then the kind of hiring
managers who are willing to take a
chance on Juniors will be willing to
talk to you
which is the same question how many
projects I do people also ask about
certifications they'll also ask how many
certifications should I get and here I
think there actually is a little bit
more of an answer uh and that is uh I
think one or two particularly one or two
really good um technical certs like you
know the solutions architect associate
that someone in chat mentioned that's
great to have if you don't have other
credentials because it shows that you've
got some awareness of the landscape and
you've got some uh ability to follow
through and study for a search but if
you find yourself getting like a bunch
of um professional or specialty level
certifications and you don't have any
experience yet I think you might be
wasting your time I think that time
maybe could be better spent getting more
Hands-On you don't want to get in a
position where it's like okay this
person knows some things maybe but they
haven't actually done anything right you
don't want to be all academics and no
application so one or two really solid
foundational technical certs uh and then
Project work that's that's where I
always encourage people to focus and
then you can be continuing to go on and
get events there's nothing wrong with
advanced search but like apply for jobs
while you're doing that don't wait to
get a bunch of advanced search before
you start preparing yourself to to
actually join the work world
yeah that's the same advice I tell other
people as well when they're like should
I get the solutions acting professional
set or should I start applying to jobs
but you know it is going to be
diminishing returns every time you do an
additional cert after getting your
Solutions after the associate or you
know some of the associate ones um but
also depends I guess on what role you
want to apply for like if your role is
more focused on like networking or like
security potentially getting one of
those certs might be helpful but yeah
just for the sake of applying to like a
cloud Engineers like solution associate
Solutions Arctic role then yeah it's
much better to focus that time doing
additional projects as opposed to
additional studs or or maybe like not I
don't want people to get confused by
additional projects it could be just you
know beefing up a project that you have
uh oh yeah adding more capabilities or
maintaining right keeping one project
and then seeing how it breaks and how
you need to fix it over time that's
sometimes that's way more valuable than
just going off and starting up a bunch
of new toy projects uh because let's be
real maintaining code and maintaining
Legacy systems is 90 of the job at a lot
of places you're going to be
interviewing at
yeah so it's kind of like the quality of
the project versus just doing as many
projects as possible quality over
quantity for sure
yeah that's the takeaway here
um one question that I've been getting
is how do you document and showcase your
projects because I've made a few videos
on project ideas and I've told people
that they can add it onto their resume
but then people are like how do I do
that and you know should I be
documenting on GitHub should I write a
blog about it uh what are your thoughts
and what have you seen uh work well with
people who you know go on to Showcase
their projects uh maybe from like a just
like from their own perspective of
learning but also from an employer
perspective like what would they like to
see
um like how would they like to see your
projects being documented I think this
is such a good question the first thing
to remember is and I kind of alluded to
this when talking about hiring managers
that might be scrolling through your
GitHub and just glaze over
I all of us are attention strapped we
have too many things to pay attention to
and not enough time and when you're
applying for a job uh you are one voice
in a huge sea of voices that all have
things they're trying to say so it's to
your advantage to find a way to cut
through that noise and usually that's
accomplished by doing Less in terms of
uh the the just the the great quantity
of stuff that you um throw out there
into the world and it's more about
having a small number of really
attention getting things that you lean
into and what I always encourage Cloud
resume Challengers to do because the
last step of the project is actually to
write a blog about your experiences and
I always encourage them to find an angle
to find a hook on that that really
encapsulates what's unique about them
and what they did we have a lot of
people coming through the cloud resume
Challenge from really interesting unique
backgrounds and I I bring up all kinds
of stories about this a lot of people
have heard the story of Dan Daniel
Singletary the commercial plumber who
came through the cloud resume challenge
just recently in the past uh we do
monthly Sprints in the December Sprint
we had someone coming through the
challenge who has spent a number of
years as a minor he does construction
underground in mines every day uh and
you know so this is a person who's
actually physically laying pipes a lot
of the time and now all of a sudden he's
laying cicd pipelines instead of you see
it that's a very very interesting uh and
you know if I'm a hiring manager I want
to know about that I want to know what
someone who has been working on physical
infrastructure for their entire career
thinks about working with digital
infrastructure there's actually a lot to
be gleaned from that and that
communicates to me again as a hiring
manager that this is someone who even
though they don't have Cloud experience
brings real world op skills that could
be Advantage advantageous to my team now
or very soon so if I'm that guy if I'm
the miner who's completed the cloud
resume challenge if I write my blog like
it doesn't need to be this 2 thousand
word thing telling about every yaml
error that I overcame the story is hey
you know I I am an experienced physical
infrastructure wielder and also look I
can Wrangle yaml too right that's that's
very interesting so find a way to tell
that in a few words you know uh make a
diagram show what you built so people
can see that at a glance so just trying
to I'm not saying to dumb it down but
I'm saying to find a way in napkin or
thumbnail fashion to express what you
did and why it matters and sometimes
that means just ruthlessly stripping
things out but the people that I've seen
go on and be successful and get hired
out of the Clutter resume challenge
um oftentimes that's something that
they're good at doing uh so when you
showcase your projects don't think
quantity again think quality think
what's the unique thing here what's the
Nugget of information that I really want
people to take away what's the headline
right and then yeah blog about it put it
on your LinkedIn tweet it if you're
comfortable being on Twitter uh just
less is more uh and you know that seems
to work well for people
yeah that's a really interesting uh
example that you provided it's sort of
like connecting the thoughts between
their you know previous experiences
versus now and then it's kind of like
you know all of this is going to be
relevant
um which brings us to another question
it's it's sort of similar in that like
you know we talked about you know skills
potentially from previous employment or
like previous uh situations could be
relevant to where you're going into for
your next step in your career uh
someone's asking should you learn
multi-cloud or focus on one or be better
at it so I think that's sort of relevant
to our conversation because we talk
about like transferable skills whether
one Cloud's transferable to the other
but I have seen a debate on this
recently on like LinkedIn where people
kind of have different perspectives on
should you learn like should you get the
Google digital Cloud leader and then AWS
Cloud practitioner Azure fundamentals
like all three or should you focus on
one and go deep what are your what's
your perspective on that yeah so like I
said at the beginning if you're brand
new don't have any experience one way or
the other start with one it's enough to
think about one without trying to bring
multiple into the mix you know you're
not going to be more attractive with no
experience on two clouds than you are
with no experience on one Cloud I don't
think once you become a professional
working engineer I do think there's some
advantage to having awareness of the
space beyond just the one Cloud you
might be working on on your day-to-day I
actually wrote an article about this for
the Google Cloud blog maybe about a year
ago and so maybe we can find that link
and put it in the show notes afterwards
but my my point in that article was hey
if you're if you're actively working in
Cloud now uh it's probably the case that
you're not working on a lot of
applications that actively use two
clouds at the same time we don't see
that kind of multi-cloud a lot in the
industry but what is likely is you're
going to be working on an application
that is primarily using one Cloud but
you're going to need to make decisions
based on a broader situational awareness
of the landscape this especially gets
true as you move higher up in your
career and you become an architect or
you become a team lead and you start
making like build versus buy decisions
you get pulled into a meeting with your
VP or with your leadership and they say
hey we heard that you know Cloud X does
this really well does that do it as well
as the decision we made on this service
on cloud y it would be a good idea to
know a little bit about both clouds so I
always recommend you get deep on one
Cloud uh and that means being Hands-On
with it building on it a lot knowing the
ins and outs knowing uh you know the the
weird little error messages and be able
to speak at an expert level about that
that's tremendously valuable for your
career and then I recommend going broad
on I would say one other Cloud I I think
two is better than one but two is also
better than three in this case I think
you know somebody just can't hold it all
in your head at all but having some
broad awareness of a second Cloud maybe
through like an associate level
technical certification uh I think is is
really beneficial to your professional
career but just don't jump the gun on
that that's something to worry about
after you get hired and have a base of
knowledge to deepen for right now you
just need to focus on again like I said
simplify right don't don't create this
confusion where you're mediocre on a lot
of things just to have a really clear
story about this is the one thing that
I'm good at this is something I've
worked hard on this is what it means to
me this is why I'm unique
yeah I personally haven't
um you know done all like the
certifications foundational
certifications for all the clouds and
but I would imagine just if you start
out it would be really confusing if you
just get the foundation ones with all of
them it just wouldn't all the services
sort of just like you know mix up in
your head it might be a bit confusing
for beginners
um yeah
so a couple other questions uh from the
chat they want to ask about your opinion
on cloud boot camps and I know this is
another topic where people are kind of
like either you know they feel really
strongly about Cloud view cam so they
feel really against it
um yeah they want to hear your opinion
on that yeah that's a good question uh I
I know wonderful people in the industry
who got their start
from cloud boot camps uh or technical
boot camps of some kind or another so
they have worked for people uh in
general I urge people to be cautious
when they're looking at boot camps I
think some of them are predatory not all
I think some of them are are fairly
predatory they make promises they can't
really keep uh and also you know some of
them will they'll pursue that kind of
learning that I was talking about
earlier where uh they you get a lot of
kind of rote facts that you learn and
then you go to look for jobs and uh you
you haven't built some bigger skills
about how to troubleshoot how to
consider situations that are outside of
just these very prescribed pre-packaged
things that that you learned uh so you
know if you're in a boot camp and it's
working well for you and you like it
great
um again I know they've worked for
people
um over time I I think I don't know I'm
skeptical of the Boot Camp Model some of
the big boot camps have really really
struggled recently because again they've
made promises to students that they
really are not able to keep at least not
at scale
so I I really think that the the problem
in the industry is on the demand side
it's teams not being set up to bring
juniors in effectively and I think boot
camps struggle partly for that reason
even the good ones so I I'm much more
interested in fixing the demand side in
helping teams be able to uh fight for
and bring on Junior headcount and know
how to bring them up then whatever we
have on the supply side whether it's
boot camps whether it's certifications
whether it's these other kinds of
learning initiatives like the cloud
resume challenge all of that will be
much more successful if the industry is
meeting them halfway on the demand side
but uh yeah before you give a ton of
your money to a boot camp do your
research make sure they really can back
up the promises that they're making
don't get scammed uh that's a lot of
your money and a lot of weeks of your
life to spend doing something that's not
going to help you more than just you
know being smart and working with a
community
yeah it is a big investment I've
sometimes seen it can go up to like
twenty thousand dollars for like a six
week program so uh always do your
research and uh you know maybe compare a
few also compare like understand your
learning style whether you need to have
a community
um and like a structured program or
maybe you could go the self-taught route
and then just go through the steps we
sort of mentioned about getting searched
and then projects next
um but yeah so this brings us to the
mistakes common mistakes when learning
cloud because I know one of them is not
doing enough research and just buying a
bunch of courses or boot camps
um as a way to learn but what are some
other mistakes you've seen when people
are learning cloud as a beginner
yeah I think we've touched on some of
them over the course of this
conversation and I want to be clear
nothing I'm going to say here is
intended as you know uh like trying to
dunk on or be mean to people that are
new uh I mean when you're new of course
you're going to make mistakes and
believe it or not making mistakes is
actually a really important part of
learning cloud you're not making any
mistakes then you have nothing to learn
from uh so maybe the most common mistake
when learning cloud is being afraid of
making any mistakes uh go go make a
bunch of mistakes you'll be a better
person for it you know go go deploy some
stuff that doesn't work that well go
build a project that has some problems
go I mean I hesitate to say this but
like you know the first time you leave a
cloud service running and you get a
surprise bill that's a mistake you're
not going to forget very soon uh so I
you know I mean I realize that can be a
scary thing and I don't mean to uh make
light of the fact that people have panic
attacks about that but uh making you
know cloud is a place for where you can
make mistakes usually uh with pretty low
uh consequences because because it's not
a bunch of Hardware you had to build you
know it's something you can you can shut
down and spin up one thing that I think
people uh and this is just along that
same vein one thing I think people do is
they they get into Cloud uh and they
start building things without thinking
carefully about uh the the costs that
they're incurring
um or how they're going to maintain and
track these things so that they don't
run into unexpected costs down the road
and something that can really help you
with that when you're starting out is to
try to use some kind of a like a cloud
playground environment uh so that even
though you're building you're in a
little bit of a safety zone where you're
not going to get hurt by a surprise bill
a clock Guru had those playgrounds when
I was there
um Google Cloud through their Google
Cloud skills boost offering also has
playgrounds there's again other training
providers and Cloud providers that have
something like that so um if you can
swing it financially because usually
those things do come with like a fixed
monthly cost of several dollars I would
look into maybe learning that way so
that you don't expose your raw wallet to
the power of the cloud before you know
what you're doing a little bit better I
think that's that's probably a really
important key thing to look at
um if you if you have the cloud resume
challenge book there's a bunch of uh uh
sort of cloud hygiene tips that I
provide in the beginning of that book
and that's certainly one of them
um others are you know just making sure
that you you have a way to uh
automatically spin stuff up and tear it
down again that you're not going to run
into a supply a surprise Bill usually if
you clean up really well after yourself
and that means getting into
infrastructure as code earlier instead
of just clicking around in the console
that's something I would encourage
people to do
something else and I've mentioned this
before a common mistake when learning
cloud is to uh try to do it on your own
uh it's much easier much better much
faster with a community of like-minded
people so please join a community
earlier rather than later don't just
float around on your own uh you're going
to do better with other people that's
that's just true of most things in life
and so uh yeah as long as you're as long
as you're with others learning from
others
um one other thing I would say is and
again this is something we've kind of
covered people oftentimes will go get a
bunch of certifications they will not do
Hands-On work and then they'll just send
out a bunch of resumes and they'll be
frustrated that they don't get any
responses back uh so something you can
do
apart from just building Hands-On is to
build in public and to start building on
server cloud services earlier where
there is a really active and um uh
excited community of practice so this is
not just about having a random Cloud
Community which maybe is what you took
from what I said before this is about
saying hey I've noticed that let's say
Google Cloud vertex AI which is a AI
Suite of AI services that Google Cloud
provides I've noticed there's a really
really interested and engaged community
on those Services there's a lot of
people trying to hire people who work on
vertex AI I should start putting out
some little projects in that area I
should start putting some things on
GitHub writing some blogs about it I
should start connecting with other
people that are doing that and then next
time there's a job opening in that area
you know they're going to think of me so
this is getting into networking not the
computer kind of networking the people
kind of networking and that often ends
up creating much better opportunities
for you than again just sending out a
bunch of random resumes into the either
and hoping that one of them comes back
and you land in a good place remember
that when you network it's not just
providing an opportunity for companies
to evaluate you it's also you evaluating
companies it's you being able to see oh
here's a company over here that seems
like they employ a bunch of people that
I really like because I've interacted
with them in the community those people
seem happy they don't seem like they're
working 90 hours a week that might be a
good place for me to spend my time right
or I know they have this big initiative
coming up and they've talked to me about
it and I'm excited about that
opportunity even before I apply so your
common mistake people make is not
getting plugged into the community and
then just sort of being at the the whims
of the job market with wherever they end
up getting placed the better connections
you build the more opportunities are
going to present themselves to you and
the earlier it's going to happen it's is
an investment of time yes is it more of
an investment of time than spending like
four years you know going back to school
no I don't think so
yeah that is something I want to dive a
bit uh deeper into because uh you know
one way is to apply to jobs and submit
your resume but there's also this other
side of uh the job space where people
you know recruiters are reaching out to
um you're finding opportunities because
you're building a personal brand it's
it's a lot of like incoming
opportunities uh that come about when
building a brand adding value to the
community and I know you've done a
really good job at that you know
regularly posted on LinkedIn and Twitter
and it's it's good for people even if
they're just not even actively on the
job search just for building a brand for
career growth and just to meet others
um performer from a job Seekers
perspective do you have some examples
you've seen where people have uh really
tried to you know build up the brand as
someone who is you know looking for a
role in this industry and then has like
XYZ skills is that something you've seen
like some good examples you can share
yeah I have uh
and it's always interesting because what
ends up happening is you're a unique
person and so the skills and interests
you have oftentimes are going to open up
an opportunity for you that may be very
tailored specifically to what you do and
what you like I think about this guy I
think his name is Riley Goodside who has
recently hired at uh scale.ai as a staff
prompt engineer because he had kind of
invented this field of prompt
engineering through the like hacking
chat GPT and other things trying to
trying to uh give it you know Wayward
input to make it do unusual things that
was just something he got interested in
and was sharing and he ended up
inventing a whole new discipline that
job title that opportunity didn't exist
before he created it for himself and if
that feels like oh well I I am not
Advanced enough to create something like
that you know I'm not saying you have to
invent something out of thin air but
like you know if you're working on an
emergent uh thing like to to use the AWS
world as an example I've seen some
people get really into the AWS cdk a
which is a programming language based
infrastructure as code solution uh and
there there's something there's a lot of
something there's a lot of interest in
but there's not a ton of people who are
really experts in that that's something
you can get good at just on your laptop
uh and then you know the more you get
plugged into that the more you may find
a company saying you know we need
someone that does that we don't have
anybody who's really good at that would
you like to come be that person for us
uh so it's almost like don't don't index
yourself off what other people are doing
uh because that's them that's their
unique thing that they're good at find
what you enjoy and and uh you know six
months down the road opportunities are
going to open up that you would never
have imagined that's how my career has
unfolded I wouldn't you know the job I
have at Google Cloud uh didn't really
exist before I was there you know it we
kind of just I I kind of worked my way
into it uh and you know those those
little holes in the universe will open
up that are exactly your size and shape
uh you just have to kind of put yourself
out there and discover who you want to
be as you're going along that's both the
most trite and I think the most profound
advice probably that I can give on that
subject
yeah there's no exact road map or
blueprint for like how to build a
personal brand it's usually quite broad
so yeah good advice over there
um you mentioned your role at Google and
that's something we haven't talked about
yet so for those who are curious uh do
you want to explain what you do at
Google you know as head of developer
media yeah my job title there is is head
of developer media now which is uh it's
it's kind of a made-up title but as I
say aren't all job titles made up uh so
what I'm doing is I'm trying to help
educate our community and the cloud
Community more broadly about uh both
what Google cloud is doing and you know
the the uh great Technologies we're
creating and releasing
but also just to help them become better
Cloud developers and whatever you know
their niche in the cloud world is help
them find that Niche help them connect
with resources that will help them do
that more effectively and efficiently we
tend to create a lot of really fun
interesting content uh so you can follow
the Google Cloud channels if you want to
get a sneak peek at some things we've
got coming out soon uh but yeah it's
it's a wonderful opportunity for me to
just kind of keep my finger on the pulse
of the community
um learn from them uh share resources
with them and uh yeah it's it's it's
been great
awesome uh I'm just looking at the chat
and uh we have a few more questions
coming in that are more specific towards
certain Services
um someone is asking how they can learn
how to use CI CD pipelines I think you
can see the question as well right you
know yes I can I'm not sure about the
question but yeah um if you can provide
some advice that would be great yeah so
asking just how to get more experience
using CI CD like cloudformation which is
aws's infrastructures code service or
terraform which is an open source
alternative created by a company called
hashicorp and there's other tools and
services out there too that fit at
different points on the the CI CD chain
uh so where can I learn how to use them
uh so he mentions one template that he's
used or he or she I don't know who's
saying this uh and still still can't
land an interview uh again
there's there's so little context in
that question that's hard for me to know
I mean you know is is cicd the problem
here and you know I I don't know if that
is the case or not right is that really
the missing piece for you I don't know
that it is uh but if what you're really
looking for is just to get more hands-on
experience with CI CD you could come to
the clitor resume challenge uh there's
actually a terraform
um mod for the challenge that's
accessible freely on the website uh
where you can uh kind of take the
default spec and you can morph it to use
all uh terraform services
uh so I would recommend giving that a
try uh
you know if you want to get more
involved with
um
infrastructure as code in general uh
there are some interesting communities I
know the AWS cdk Community I think they
have like like presentation days you
know that you could go and get involved
with
um but again I think it just comes down
to practice building some projects and
actually building some some templates
and not just copy pasting an existing
template but writing some stuff from
scratch beating your head against it
figuring out where you made a mistake
and then trying it again so Cloud resume
challenge might be a nice uh Next Step
because there's a lot of
infrastructure's code in that uh in that
project
yeah and I think from a job search
perspective maybe try to implement some
of the tips we mentioned today with
personal branding uh you know like maybe
write a blog on what you've built and
then sharing that on LinkedIn those
could be some other ways to help you
land that interview and maybe yeah push
you towards closer to the role you want
to apply for uh but yeah if you want to
share some more context as well just
feel free to
um in the chat oh yeah they just did so
there you go yeah yeah I I would uh yeah
if just what you need is you know you
have a gap there you know the whole you
need to fill it come to the cloud resume
Challenge and focus on the IAC pieces
you can automate every single one of
those 16 steps and by the time you get
to the end of that at least you'll know
more of what you don't know that would
be my suggestion
yeah exactly
um and I'm just looking at the time uh
we have time for a few more questions
but I like to cover 2023 Cloud Trends uh
because I think this will be useful with
people who are wondering what should I
learn in 2023 is there an area of cloud
to look out for and just maybe yeah from
I know a lot of people watching uh
looking to land a job in the cloud are
there anything specific to 2023 you know
given the market conditions
um that could be good to keep an eye out
on yes so keep in mind
um you know whatever we say the trends
for 2023 are a lot of companies
particularly a lot of larger companies
you know they're still catching up with
the trends from 2013 right so uh there's
uh like there's this really fat tale of
uh work on just really basic bread and
butter Cloud skills like Automation and
being able to do Cloud networking and
doing Cloud migrations and all of that
is just really really nuts and work that
needs to be done and there's lots of
opportunities to do it so I don't be too
discouraged because you're not working
on the quote unquote latest and greatest
2023 Cloud Trend but some things that I
do see being uh really really impactful
and interesting for for the current year
one of them is software supply chain
security if you're interested in
anything in the security space or even
if you're just in the cloud development
or like platform engineering space I
would uh get familiar with what this is
Google cloud has really done a lot of
work to um try to advocate for Best
Practices here if you want to know what
software supply chain security or s3c is
some good places to start would be
salsa.dev that's spelled slsa.dev I'll
put it in chat here uh and that's a
place where Google and a bunch of other
partners have have laid out some things
you can do to help protect your code on
the way to production as it goes through
build stages and Source stages and
packaging stages and there's some clear
diagrams there to help you understand
what they're talking about and I would
dig in then from there to learn more
about how you can protect specific
aspects of your supply chain learn some
of the tools that are available to help
you with that I think AI is going to be
a major Trend we're seeing it right we
mentioned chat GPT even in this call as
well and you're going to see I think all
the cloud providers you know really
scrambling to show what they have and to
to differentiate uh so if you are not
familiar with using a cloud AI Services
uh in a project now might be a great
time to pick a project that involves
some of that again Google Cloud because
I work there I'll shut them out they
have a great Suite of services to help
with that vertex Ai and others so that
would be a really really great thing to
put into a cloud project this year uh
and I think beyond that you know it's
just I mentioned platform engineering uh
in passing a moment ago but I think
that's a strong Trend you're seeing more
Cloud teams consolidating around having
software developers who are writing
applications and they have these
platform teams who are creating layers
of infrastructure that these
applications run on and this is kind of
the next evolution of the quote unquote
devops or infra ops world that we've had
the last few years so learn what
platform engineer hearing is what the
components of it are see what gaps on
that might be missing in your resume and
then work on plugging those
yeah uh good point with the you know not
all the companies are up to
date as Cloud Trends so there will still
be Demand on a lot of things you know
you mentioned like back in 2013 like I
think just like uh maybe
maybe like migrating something like an
on-premises server onto the cloud that's
something that a lot of companies are
still looking to do so I wanted to ask
uh still on the topic of cloud Trends
people have asked me Are there specific
roles in Cloud that will be particularly
in demand for 2023 or maybe roles that
uh yeah or on the flip side roles to not
look out for yeah well like you
mentioned a minute ago Lucy uh this is a
weird year for Tech there's certainly a
downturn uh we're seeing lots and lots
of layoffs across the industry uh and so
uh I think something that I've heard
anecdotally uh has been an area of cuts
has been like internal tooling teams
which makes sense right if you're
working on something that's not directly
making money for customers you're
probably going to be seen as less
integral to the business so if you're
looking for a role you're evaluating
resumes and you have the luxury of
choosing which job you'd like to have uh
it might be a good idea to just really
buy us for taking a role that directly
supports code that is making money for
the company uh so if you're on if you're
like seven teams deep from the customer
and you're working on some internal tool
that enables another tool not saying
that works not important but it that may
be harder to justify when the company
starts looking at Cuts uh so with that
said roles that I think are continuing
to be uh in high demand certainly data
engineering so being able to work with
the pipelines that get data out of
databases and into other applications
where it can be sliced and diced uh it
continues to be an area of great need
obviously Ai and anything related to uh
being able to integrate AI Services into
applications is big uh and yeah we we
continue to see uh just strong need for
the the bread and butter rolls of uh
security and platform engineering and
honestly software development as well
space roles like Solutions Architects
um
yeah like sales development reps right
and sometimes people don't uh you know
associate these with Cloud engineering
but of course you're absolutely right um
Solutions Architects do a lot of
Hands-On work at Google Cloud we have
something called customer engineers and
you know they are a little bit more on
the sales side but they are very very
technical very Hands-On with with code
and with cloud
uh and yeah I mean it just you know uh
a lot of companies are trying to angle
for profitability this year from what
I've seen and heard uh and that may
affect their growth budget which may
affect roles on like the sales and
marketing side so I would be aware of
that but that's getting a little bit out
over my skis in terms of understanding
exactly how all those complicated
Dynamics are at Play
yeah and I think for cloud Learners it's
sort of you can pivot between different
roles you don't have to be like I want
to become a Solutions architect and
that's it like a lot of the skills you
learn through projects and
certifications could be relevant in
other areas and that could be you know
trying to do more projects on a specific
topic that you see like has like an open
role for so I think maybe the takeaway
would just be to keep an open mind
um 2023
I guess it's like it's hard to tell
maybe even at this point like what roles
would be like particularly in demand but
we did mention a few just then but um
yeah I guess just be open to any sort of
uh role where you can get to use your
Cloud skills so we're closing in on the
hour now first but I usually like to ask
people what is their biggest uh advice
they have for the viewers we have 105
people watching at the moment and I know
a lot of people would be interested in
replaying this or people who aren't able
to make it live who will be watching
this recording what advice would you
have for them like I think people here
are mainly job Seekers or potentially
people who are in already in the cloud
role like let's say like a cloud
engineer role but looking to progress
their career into becoming like for
example Solutions architect Cloud
architect and they're just looking at
using Hands-On skills as a way to
further their career
yeah well it's hard to narrow it down to
one but can I give two
sure so the the first one is learn to
code whether you are brand new to Cloud
whether you are in a technical role of
some kind but you're not really doing a
lot of Hands-On programming day-to-day
learn to code uh it's going to open a
lot of doors for you you will not regret
doing it I promise hey with you know
things like GitHub copilot it's easier
to get a lot of code written than ever
so uh learn to code it will be a
tremendous uh Force multiplier and value
add for your career second thing and I
said this earlier is just be yourself
and that means being authentical
yourself it means being the most
well-rounded version of yourself it
means being the most empathetic version
of yourself that's both the most trite
and the most profound advice that I can
give you because ultimately you know uh
lots of things get automated away every
day but what's not going to get
automated away is someone who
understands the business understands who
they are understands what they like and
is willing to grow and adapt in order to
uh just keep seeking that that true
version themselves so I don't don't lose
Hearts you know if you're having uh
trouble finding a job opportunity right
now just continue to put yourself out
there continue to to grow in your
understanding of what you want to do and
I I genuinely do believe that uh you're
you've got a bright future because I've
seen it over and over and over again
yeah mindset is a big part of this as
well just stay optimistic and you know
don't give up too early uh be resilient
and focus on your learning and applying
those skills really good takeaway is
there I'll just thank you I'll just put
the link to your LinkedIn profile uh
also on Twitter as well one second so
people can connect with you and uh
follow you along your journey with you
know providing advice to Cloud learners
and cool okay I think yeah this brings
us to time so that's all the time we
have left but thank you so much for us
for adding so much value to the tech
with Lucy Community uh a lot of the
advice has been super helpful and um it
I learned a lot of things as well from
this chat so thank you so much and for
those uh for everyone who's tuning in at
the moment live we really appreciate it
um and for those who are watching this
recording if you have any questions just
leave it in the comments and um I'll try
to get back to as many people as I can
but yeah thank you so much for us uh
we'll speak soon perfect thanks Lucy
wonderful to be here
all right bye